. Dankeschön, Dankeschön, ich freue mich. Vielen Dank für dieses Intro an Max, sehr knackig, sehr kurz, das gefällt uns. Wie sein Name, wie sein Name, kurz und knackig Max. Kurz und knackig, man muss sich auch mal kurz halten können, einfach mal kurze, präzise Sätze, damit kommt man gut an, glaube ich. Das funktioniert gut, vielen, vielen Dank an dich Max. Gut, das ist der Satz, in dem du hast gesagt, dass um zehn Zeilen lang war, Immanuel Kant. Du meinst, ich habe letztens, es ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich dir nicht meine beste Seite zeige. Was ist denn die Seite, die du mir zeigst? Ja, weil in der Regel, wir nehmen immer so in der Mitte der Woche auf und da ist bei mir immer Waschtag. Und du siehst mich meistens am Waschtag, wo meine ganze hochwertige gute Kleidung in der Wäschetrommel rotiert gerade. Und an meinem Körper prangt eigentlich nur der Bodensatz der Garderobe. Also ich kenne jetzt das Banner in meinem Rucksack, wo Intervention draufsteht, kann ich erstmal wieder mitnehmen nach Hause. Ich muss mir keine Sorgen machen, das beruhigt mich auf sehr vielen Ebenen, dass du das gerade gesagt hast. Nein, mir ist wirklich sehr, sehr klar, was ich dir hier Woche um Woche zumute. Du putzt dich immer raus, du hast die glänzende Uhr. Ich ziehe mir mal ein Hemd an. Du hast die glänzenden Schuhe, schönes Hemd, du siehst immer gut aus, hast dir irgendwie noch so eine Brosche angesteckt, so kleine modische Akzente gesetzt und ich schluder dir hier entgegen und es ist fast schon beleidigend, was ich dir da biete eigentlich. Ist nachfraud. Ist nachfraud. Aber ich finde es auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen sympathisch, weil ich immer denke, um mich herum werden alle so Age of Empires HHose an. Ich habe meine Age of Empires-Jogginghose an. Von dem Age of Empires 2 Definitive Edition Release Event in Berlin. Warum gibt es die? Warum gibt es die? Warum gibt es die? Warum, ihr müsst nicht Jogginghosen. Es sind doch Podcast-Ufo-Jogginghosen, wurden uns mal geschenkt von irgendeinem Booker oder sowas. Oh, das ist die beste, die nutze ich bis heute. Ich verstehe aber nicht, warum man das macht. Da ist nicht mal ein Podcast-Ufo-Logo drauf, da ist einfach ein Adidas-Logo drauf. Das ist einfach, dem ist ein Jogginganzug geschenkt. Vor allem, je länger die Woche wird, desto mehr werde ich zur wandelnden Windfassäule, desto mehr trage ich Merch. Weil bei mir unten ganz im Kleiderschrank ist immer nur Merch. Am Anfang klar, da hat man mal irgendwie hier den Anzug und sowas, aber dann gegen Ende nur noch die Jogginghosen mit Age of Empires Logo. Aber erst kommt Merch und dann kommt dein eigener Merch. Deswegen, du streckst mir auch gerade feuchschulich deinen Animal Squatch-Shirt entgegen. Von daher, also das kommt eigener Merch, eigener Merch, eigener Merch, mein Gesicht auf meinem Shirt, also so Weihnachtsgeschenke, ja. Das würde ich eh gern machen. Ich glaube, ich hätte Lust, ein Buch zu veröffentlichen, nur, aber auf den Büchern ist ja hinten oft ein Bild des Autoren drauf. Auch in schwarz-weiß, als es so aussieht, als wäre der Autor gestorben. Ja, und einfach nur, um mich in die U-Bahn zu setzen, mit meinem eigenen Buch und das ganz offen prägnant zu lesen, dass die Leute genau sehen, der liest sein eigenes Buch. Nur für diesen Gag würde ich durch den gesamten Weg gehen, um ein Buch zu veröffentlichen.
Einfach nur, um in der U-Bahn zu sitzen und mein eigenes Buch zu lesen. Und jeder sieht es. Ja, schnitt du das mit so einer Maske, die ein halbes Gesicht bedenkt und alle denken, ha, guck mal, der sieht so ähnlich aus wie der Autor. Ich finde es aber auch gut, wenn man so Genre mischt, wenn das Autorenbild auf dem Buchcover ist dann so nachdenklich mit so einer Geige in der Hand. Irgendwie wo dann so einfach so, ja, das haben wir noch Foto übrig von meinem Musikalbum, aus dem nichts geworden ist, nimm die. Oder der sitzt auch in der U-Bahn. Das Bild des Autoren ist auch jemand, der in der U-Bahn sitzt. Aber das Foto ist so eine POV von demjenigen, der ihn gegenüber sitzt und ihn beobachtet. Man sieht also noch die Knie von demjenigen, der ihn beobachtet. Ah, das ist gut. Und dann denkst du, dann sitzt du da und siehst dich mit dem Buch, was du sitzt, was das exakte Bild deines visuellen Umfelds zeigt. Das fände ich schön. Guck mal, das wäre was für unsere Prankshow. Für unsere Wie lang würde es dauern, bis jemandem auffällt, dass da das Bild gerät ist. Dass irgendwas im Argen ist. Der Titel ist final. Mit Guido Kanz. Der ist gesetzt, mit Guido Kanz. Ich wollte sagen, dass ich stolz bin, dich zu kennen. Jemanden zu kennen, der dem Kleidung so scheißegal ist, dem offensichtlich Mode nichts bedeutet, der keine Spureitelkeit hat. Das finde ich so schön, dass ich jemanden kenne, der da so gar keinen Maßstab hat, was ich total einfach, weil das was anderes ist. Zum einen bietest du mir immer eine Story, weil ich kann immer sagen, wenn es um Mode geht oder so oder um materialistische Dinge, ich hätte da diesen einen Kumpel, dem ist das alles scheißegal, es ist immer schön, das einwerfen zu können. Achso, ich dachte, ich bin, okay, ja. Auf der anderen Seite finde ich es aber total cool, dass in so einer Welt, wo es ja nur noch darum geht und alle wollen immer die neuesten Sneaker haben und laufen den neuesten Trends hinterher, läufst du hinterher, aber ganz weit hinten. Hast den Bus verpasst. Aber das kennst du ja gar nicht mehr, du hast ja auch neue Freunde seit einem Jahr, du bist in einer komplett anderen Welt. Ich habe mein Leben geändert, ja. Du bist jetzt nur noch in so Innenarchitekturkreisen. Ich habe übrigens letztens, du bist ja ein Freund der Innenarchitektur, ich habe mir letztens Gedanken gemacht über die nächste App. Nee, ich bin nicht Freund, ich bin ein färter Bekannter. Okay, ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht über eine App, und zwar ist es die App Bullshit, heißt die, und zwar kannst du in die App Augmented Reality und die zeigt dir an, was in deinem Zimmer Bullshit ist? Fast. Du kannst dort ein Gesprächsthema oder ein Themenfeld eingeben, zum Beispiel Innenarchitektur. Und die App gibt dir dann so ein paar Schlagworte, die du im Gespräch einsetzen kannst, wie zum Beispiel Open Shelf. Habe ich letztens gelernt, Open Shelf bedeutet einfach, dass die Regale keine Türen haben und man sieht, was drin ist. Das ist die Open Shelf-Ästhetik.
Ja, ich habe eine Open Shelf-Küche zum Beispiel.
Herrlich, das heißt, du kannst direkt in den Raum gehen und sagen, also diese Open Shelf-Ästhetik ist ja ein Traum hier. Was mir gefällt, Charles und Ray Eames hilft halt auch. Das kenne ich nicht. Zwei Designer, die den berühmten Eames-Lounge-Chair zum Beispiel gebaut haben, die man erkennt, und die ganz viele Stühle. Eames-Chair sind die bekanntesten Stühle von Leuten, die anfangen, was natürlich zu halten. Was auch spannend ist, Mid-Century ist auch so ein Bullshit-Wort. Schreibt mit, Leute, ihr könnt das alles verwenden. Finde ich ganz gut. Dann Indoor-Outdoor-Living oder Outdoor, dass es innen so wirkt, als wäre man draußen. Open Space Living ist auch gut. Open Space Living, ganz wichtig. Und die App gibt dir dann so ein paar Schlagwörter zu jedem Thema, einfach dass du dich so an drei Begriffen durch den Abend hangeln kannst, weil du kannst ja so Begriffe neutral einbauen. Also diese neuen Open Shelf Trends, ich finde die faszinierend. Du musst nicht wissen, was es ist. Was findest du denn da so faszinierend? Naja, ich finde, es ist einfach ein ganz neuer Impuls in der Szene und ich finde es einfach toll, was die verschiedenen Designer da auch
draus machen. Es ist eine ganz simple Idee eigentlich,
aber ich finde, die ist so unglaublich
ergiebig. Okay, und was sagen Sie zu Charles
und Ray Eames? Ach, mir
gefällt nicht alles, aber
ich finde, da sind schon viele tolle Impulse
dabei. Open floor.
Und die Open
Moment, ganz kurz. Warum schauen Sie
die anderen auf ihr Handy eigentlich? Und die Open floor
Ästhetik ist ja wirklich ein Traum, also
wie da alles offen ist, das ist ja
Wünschte, die wir heute noch nicht mehr haben, haben wir heute noch eine gute Idee, die wir heute noch nicht mehr haben, ganz kurz. Warum schauen Sie die anderen auf Ihr Handy eigentlich? Und die Open-Floor-Ästhetik ist ja wirklich ein Traum. Also wie da alles offen ist, das ist ja wirklich klasse. Ich finde das mega. Was ich auch häufig mache, ist, wenn ich Leute treffe, wo ich Angst habe, dass unangenehme Pausen entstehen könnten, Gesprächspausen, schreibe ich mir vorher gerne eine Liste mit Themen. Auf die Hand, auf den Arm wirklich? In meine Notiz-App, wo was ich sagen könnte, falls man mal auf dem Klo ist oder so oder kurz eine Pause entsteht und man aufs Handy guckt oder so, kann man kurz in die Notiz-App zurate ziehen, wo dann ein paar Themen stehen. Zum Beispiel stand da lange Tenet drin. Einfach so, weil war ein Film, man konnte gut draufzugreifen. Es gab ein bisschen was zu erzählen. Ich hatte mittlerweile in der Tenet-Zeit hatte ich so gut 15 Minuten, tight 15 Minutes Material für Tenet-Jokes und Anekdoten, war ja auch ein paar im Kino so, da habe ich was zu erzählen gehabt, das war mir klar. Und das stand da längere Zeit drin, mittlerweile habe ich so eine Möbel gelöscht. Aber ich habe wirklich so eine Liste mit To-Go-Themen, falls der Smalltalk erlischt. Und bist du gut darin, dann das aktuelle Gespräch auf diese Themen zu leiten oder sind es harte Cuts? Nee, wie ihr im Podcast auch wisst, also ihr wisst es ja am besten, wie schlecht ich darin bin. Ihr seid ja am häufigsten in der Situation, dass wir unangenehme Gespräche führen. Und du kannst es ja sehr gut, ich hingegen bin eher so ... Ich war letzte Woche im Phantasialand, und du sagst, hä, ich war grad mitten in meiner Krebs-Story. Ich hab jetzt Krebs, was du halt immer so sagst. Ja. Und dann würde ich ... Ich drehte da einfach immer so krass rein. Ich bin nicht so gut darin, das dann da drauf zu lenken. Ja. Apropos Krebs, kennst du eigentlich diese Achterbahn mit den krebsförmigen Achterbahnen? Nee, aber du hast mir letzte Woche schon von deinem Phantaiserland-Aufenthalt erzählt, Stefan. Ich war auch in Tenet. Okay, cool. Ja, finde ich gut. Nee, habe ich auch schon gemacht. Und das ist ja so ein Prinzip so eine App, die du hast. Für lange Telefonate ist es auch manchmal gut irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, ob du viel telefoniert hast in meinem Leben. Ich hatte immer eine Zeit, wo ich viel telefoniert habe irgendwie und dann immer so eine Stunde lang oder so so und dann mal so ausquatschen und das hat mir immer Angstschweiss auf die Stirn getrieben. Und da habe ich ihm vorher dann wirklich so ein Redaktionsmeeting gemacht, so ist heute Tag des Donuts, Tag des Donuts, irgendwie der Karpfen des Monats, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, was sagt Karpen an die, was sagt Teppiche weekly, was sind die neuen Trends im Teppicheleben, Jeder hat eine Meinung zum Thema. Auch ein paar One-Liner geschrieben zu den aktuellen Themen bei Bild.de.
Klar, absolut, wunderbar. Und dann einfach
die besten Themen kommen dann rein.
Oder wie Rainer Kallmund sagt, schade.
Oder sowas.
Wie Sebastian Edatis
diese
2011er Gags. Leute, die ich
nur über Gags kenne.
Sebastian Edati, Rainer Kallmund, Jenny Elvers, weiß ich nicht, wer das ist, genau, Sylvie Mais, Boris Becker, aber der kommt sofort, wenn es um Pleite-Gags geht und so. Das stimmt schon, das ist gut. Und kam es gut an mit deinem Telefonpartner, dein Late-Night-Show. Richtig gut. Die eingespielten Lacher waren ein bisschen mehrgürtig am Anfang, aber ich dachte mir, ich versuche es ein bisschen aufzubreppen. Aber ich habe mir auch schon für Sachen so Notizen gemacht, zum Beispiel habe ich einmal Schluss gemacht und habe mir dafür extra Notizen gemacht, mach heute Schluss, kein Bullshit jetzt. Und wenn du dir unsicher bist, dann liest diese Nachricht, die ich gestern geschrieben habe, glaub mir einfach.
Glaub mir, du fühlst dich gerade nicht gut. Du bist gerade unglücklich.
Es ist ganz schwer, aber tu es einfach.
Sie wird dir das Gefühl geben, weil das hatte ich auch mal, aber dann verstehe ich auch sie nicht, weil ich hatte dann so ein Schlussmachgespräch, wo sie dann mehr oder weniger den Punkt eingenommen hat, nee, ist doch alles gut, du kannst das nicht mit mir Schluss machen, wieso sollst du das mit mir Schluss machen, das kriegen wir doch alles wieder hin, wo man denkt, das ist wie so, jemand hat gesagt, er hat jetzt keinen Bock, mit einem Playstation zu spielen, warum soll ich weiterhin mit ihm Playstation spielen? Es ist auch so ein merkwürdiges Konzept, dass man das begründen muss. Ja, also man kann einfach sagen, so nee, ich will nicht mehr, so und dann, ja, warum? Und so, ja. Vor allem, es schwimmt immer das Damoklesschwert der Verletzung darüber, im passenden Sinne. Weil du willst ja nicht verhälsen. Und oft sind Gründe des Schlussmachens, sind ja manchmal einfach auch Gründe, die das gegenüber verletzen. Ich mag deine Seife nicht. Ehrlichkeit. Du hast eine ganz unangenehme Seife, danach tagelang riechen meine Hände. Was ist das für eine fucking Seife? Ich kann den Geruch nicht zuordnen, die fühlt sich komisch an. Ich kann mir aber auch nicht einfach, wenn ich bei dir bin, nicht die Hände waschen. Ich kann nicht eine eigene Seife mitnehmen, sonst sagst du, warum riechen deine Hände nach Pfirsich. Das geht nicht. Wenn du die App verwechselst und dann sagst, dein ganzes Open-Shelf-System, das macht mich einfach wahnsinnig. Charles und Ray Eames, immer höre ich nur, es geht immer nur die ganze Zeit um Charles und Ray Eames und dieses Open-Floor-Space-Living, das gehöre ich gegen den Strich. Bitte was? Und du sagst, tut mir leid, ich hätte die falsche App offen. Ja, ich komme noch immer rein. Ach ja, manchmal sind es auch Kleinigkeiten, manchmal sind es es einfach Details, es ist einfach, die Sonne strahlt mir ins Gesicht manchmal und das geht nicht. Ich mag deine Wohnung nicht. Das sind eigentlich die besseren Gründe, als wenn man die Personen kritisiert. Zurück zur App Bullshit. Glaubst du nicht, dass wir diese App alle sind? Spielen wir nicht alle? Podcast meinst du? Nein, alle Menschen, spielen wir nicht alle Menschen,okas meinst du? Nein, alle Menschen.
Spielen wir nicht alle Menschen, die meinen, etwas zu wissen, zu können,
blenden wir nicht ...
In allen Themen sind wir irgendwelche Imposter,
die die Oberfläche ankratzen, um da den Smalltalk zu überleben.
Sind wir nicht alles Maschinen, die einfach nur Smalltalk überleben wollen?
Wir sind ein bisschen so KIs, die den Turing-Test bestanden haben. Wir gehen gerade so als Menschen durch im Gespräch mit anderen Menschen. Wir wollen alle nicht auffliegen. Wir wollen alle im Smalltalk nicht als komplette Dös-Buddle auffliegen. Und deswegen fangen wir an. Was genau meinst du mit Dös-Buddle? Als komplette Vollidioten aufzufliegen. Und deswegen fangen wir an, uns dann für so vordergründiges Wissen anzueignen, um halt den Smalltalk zu überstehen. Ich glaube, dass viele Leute auch solche Begriffe übernehmen, ohne zu wissen, was es ist. Es fällt mir bei Filmen oft auch oft auf, mache ich ja auch manchmal, dass man dann sagt, ja, keine Ahnung, das Pacing war irgendwie einfach nicht richtig. Was war das, was war, und du hoffst einfach, dass es keine Gegenfrage war. Und dann so, hä, warum denn, ich fand das war perfekt.
Und da bin ich auch nicht auf der Seite von Leuten, die dann so Nachfragen stellen. Das ist genauso wie Tobi. Sorry, ich muss ganz kurz was zu Tobi sagen. Tobi, es ist vielleicht jetzt 17, 16 Jahre zu spät. Wer ist das jetzt? Ich will aber an der Stelle nochmal sagen, lass es Tobi. Tobi war nämlich der, der, ich habe nämlich in der Schule ein Buchreferat gehalten über ein Buch, das ich natürlich nicht gelesen habe. Und dann musste man ein Handout machen und als Handout hatte ich das Einzige, was ich in dem Buch gefunden habe, weil ich hatte keine Ahnung, was in dem Buch steht, aber hinten war eine Karte drin. So, das war irgendwie so ein Fernsehroman in irgendeiner Hexenwelt, Bullshit. Da war eine K Karte, na geil. Dann kopiere ich die und teile die als Handout aus. Hatte nichts mit meinem Referat zu tun, gar nichts. Aber es kommt einfach gut, man sagt, hier habt ihr alle mal die Karte. Und dann erzähle ich, ja, es geht um die Lisa und die weiß nicht, ob sie eine Hexe ist und ob sie die Kräfte hat. Und man denkt ja auch in so einem Setting, ihr seid alle im selben Team. Absolut. Und ihr spielt gegen das
Team Lehrer. Lehrer und Zeit.
Lehrer und Zeit sind die beiden
großen Feindel. Wobei Zeit kann auch ein großer Verwündeter sein.
Absolut. Und dann
hast du ja ein Referat gehalten und denkst dir, okay, das
klang halbwegs sinnvoll, der Lehrer hat das Buch
natürlich auch nicht gelesen, du kannst ja irgendwas ausdenken.
Und dann streckt einer
die Hand. Es ist Tobi und denkst dir,
ah geil, danke Tobi, du stellst jetzt eine Frage.
Aber Tobi beliebt, cool, uncool,
Opfer. Total beliebt und das macht
Vielen Dank. Und dann streckt einer die Hand. Es ist Tobi und denkst dir, ah geil, danke Tobi, du stellst jetzt eine Frage. Aber Tobi beliebt, cool, uncool, Opfer. Total beliebt und das macht es ja so schlimm. Beliebt, guter Kumpel von mir, gross sportlich, Basketballteam sehr gross, schön, kommt bis an den Ring vom Basketballkorb hin, cooler Typ. Klar, ich habe jetzt mit den Sportlern nicht so viel zu tun, aber den mag ich so. Das ist so ein Sportler, der sich auch nicht zuade ist, irgendwie mit den fetten Nerds rumzuhängen. Und deswegen, Tobi, absolut Premium-Kontakt bei mir auf jeden Fall, ganz weit oben. Wo saß der so im Klassenbefühl? Zweite Reihe. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist ein Zweite-Reihe-Typ. Und dann dachte ich mir, geil, Tobi ist auf meiner Seite und stellt jetzt die Alibi-Frage. Sowas wie, was hat dir denn besonders gut gefallen? So, wo jeder weiß, da kannst du noch mehr Bullshit erzählen.
Oder was ich nicht verstanden habe und frag dann nochmal was nach, was schon gesagt wurde, was ich einfach wiederholen kann.
Das wäre geil lange Tobi. Und dann kommt eine Frage und er deutet auf die Karte und meint, hier steht Agathas Haus. Wer ist denn Agatha? Ähm, nichts. Und da dachte ich mir wirklich, ich habe nicht mal über die, ich habe nicht mal nachgedacht darüber, jetzt irgendein Bullshit mehr auszudenken, sondern ich war wütend. Meine gesamte Gedankenleistung war konsumiert von Wut und sag mal, was fällt dir ein? Hast du das auch dann verpackt in deiner Antwort ein bisschen? Ja, Agatha wurde leider ins Exil geschickt, weil sie hat nämlich, als sie Lisa ein Referat war, hat sie dumme Scheissfragen gestellt und deswegen lebt sie da jetzt alleine, weil niemand mehr mit ihr Zeit verbringen will.
Der Teufel hat sie bestraft, weil sie ihre Freundin in die Pfanne gehauen hat. Tausend Jahre Hölle. Will ich das nochmal sagen, seid kein Tobi, wenn ihr merkt, ihr habt jemanden im Gespräch, der redet Bullshit, dann winkt es einfach durch und sagt, ja, Pacing war so ein bisschen mittel und redet dann weiter über die Dinge, über die ihr reden. Was mir neulich mal aufgefallen ist, und das spielt genau da rein, ist, lasst Dinge unausgesprochen.
Weil es ist total spannend, mir ist aufgefallen, ich habe offensichtlich Menschen, die man mag sich nicht.
Und das ist unter einer grossen Schicht von Smalltalk und gesellschaftlichen Gepflogenheiten und keine Ahnung Alltagsgedöns, das schmiert drunter, man mag sich nicht. Und es wurde schon oft gesagt, sowas wie, ja, da müssen wir uns mal treffen, nie reagiert oder man hat offensichtlich gelogen, weil natürlich widerspricht man sich ja manchmal.
Man sagt, an dem Abend habe ich das und das gemacht, nächste Woche kommt raus oder, keine Ahnung, da habe ich mit einer anderen Kollegin was gemacht oder sowas von ihr.
Zum Beispiel hat man sich nicht gesehen oder man widerspricht sich im sozialen Gefüge, weil es irgendwie Arbeitskollege ist oder sowas. Das passiert ja. Es kommt ja raus ab und zu. Lügen werden ja offenbart. Aber solange man die nicht anspricht, ist alles gut. Sobald aber mein Gegenüber anspricht, Moment, aber da warst du doch mit dem und dem unterwegs, es ist vorbei. Lustigerweise, zwischen uns allen steht doch immer eine unausgesprochene Wahrheit. Und so oft sind wir nicht bereit, die zu sehen, weil wir ja selber an diesen ganzen Smalltalk-Scheiss glauben. Du bist ja auch irgendwann so Method-Acting-mäßig drin. Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Smalltalk mit jemandem führst, denkst du da die ganze Zeit im Kopf, ich hasse den, ich hasse den, ich hasse den, ich bin gerade nur nett, ich bin gerade nur nett. Nein, das denkt man ja nicht. Vielleicht denkt man das am ersten Gespräch oder sowas, aber legt man ja irgendwann ab. Und irgendwann führst du da wirklich einen Smalltalk, bis du dich irgendwann anfreundest mit dem, weil man das so oft gut gemacht hat, dass man dann irgendwie so ein Level aufsteigt. Aber darunter kann ja trotzdem immer noch so eine Hass sein... Ja, absolut. Und es gibt ja Codes, die wir uns als Menschheit ausgedacht haben für ich mag dich nicht, wie wenn du dreimal sagst, ich habe keine Zeit, weil es jeder okay, der mag mich nicht, will mich nicht treffen, aus. Aber manchmal ist es gibt so ein paar Leute, wo ich mir einfach nicht sicher bin, ob die mich nicht mögen oder ob die einfach inkompetent sind. Oder ob, weil die, also es gibt zum Beispiel manche Personen, die machen immer was anderes als das, worum ich sie bitte.
Ich bitte die darum, mach doch bitte dies und sie machen explizit was anderes. Und dann will ich fragen, hast du mich? Und das ist eine offene Frage, es ist wirklich eine offene Frage. Sag ja und wir haben kein Problem, aber ich will es dann schon gerne wissen, weil manchmal bricht das dann auch zusammen, dass diese Kommunikation nicht stattfindet und dann so, magst du mich nicht oder bist du dumm oder was oder lass uns offen darüber reden, es müsste vielleicht so einen Tag im Jahr geben, wo man dann doch The Purge, wo man dann einfach so eine Social Purging, wo man jedem, den man nicht mag, so einen schwarzen Brief schickt oder so, damit das einfach geklärt ist. Aber man verpflichtet sich dazu, das nie anzusprechen, sondern es immer begraben zu halten. Ich finde das interessant, weil man will das alles aufrechterhalten, immer diesen Schein. Wir leben in einer kompletten Scheinwelt durch so gesellschaftlichen Smalltalk-Scheiss. Aber man mag doch nicht so viele Menschen. Jeder von uns mag doch nur so drei, vier Menschen. Ja, stimmt schon, ja. Mit denen man dann auch regelmäßig Zeit verbringt. Aber es wird immer vorgegaukelt irgendwie, dass man alle mögen muss oder mit allen eine gute Zeit hat und so. Aber es ist auch gut, dass man das ungesprochen lässt. Ja. Wir leben alle so ein bisschen in unserer kunterbunten Welt. Ich weiß nicht genau, wofür ich gerade plädiere. Weil das sollte man ja auch nicht auflösen. Das ist ja was Gutes. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich finde, man soll das zelebrieren. Nee, weil der wäre ja Tobi. Ich finde, ja, Tobi würde ja sagen, sorry, raus, Tobi raus. Der würde ja sagen so, hä, aber du warst doch letzte Woche gesagt, du bist mit Mike unterwegs gewesen. Ja, ich kann auch diese Kritik immer nicht verstehen, was zum Beispiel viele Leute über die Amerikaner sagen, die seien so oberflächlich und die würden immer gute Laune haben,
obwohl sie nicht sind. Und ich sage, ja genau, das ist es
doch. Die sind besser.
Ja, es ist mir doch egal, ob die Person sich wirklich freut,
mich zu sehen oder nicht. Das ist ja völlig irrelevant.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass mich jeder hasst und ich jeden
hasse, aber besser, man wird einem
vorgegaukelt, dass man eine gute Zeit hat und
dass man auf dieser oberen Ebene
zusammen Schlittschuh fahren kann, unabhängig, was
unter im Keller passiert.
Ja, aber was ich häufig höre ist dann auch so über Menschen, die dann so sind, man weiß nicht, woran man bei denen ist. Und dann denke ich mir aber, ja, gut, okay. Wenn du nicht weißt, woran du bist, hasst er dich wahrscheinlich. Ja, oder derjenige spielt schlecht genau, derjenige hasst dich zu sehr, als dass er die soziale Gepflogenheit des normalen Smalltalks hätte aufrechterhalten können. Ja, wobei ich weiß nicht, woran ich bin, ist auch ein Code für, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, dass er mich mag. Und ich will mich mit der Wahrheit konfrontieren, dass die Person mich nicht mag. Genau. Eine andere Wahrheit, mit der wir uns vielleicht auch konfrontieren müssen, und zwar haben wir letzte Woche darüber gesprochen im Podcast, und da kamen einige Rückmeldungen von euch, und das möchte ich kurz zur Aufklärung nutzen, und zwar das grosse Thema rote Augen bei Fotografien. Wir haben darüber gesprochen, es gab eine Zeit, in der Fotografien rote Augen hinterlassen haben.
Und wir haben eine tolle Mail bekommen, und zwar von einer Frau, die eine Weiterbildung zur Augenärztin macht. Und die findet es schade, dass die Technik so weit ist, dass es diesen Reflex nicht mehr gibt. Und zwar schreibt sie, man sieht tatsächlich den Rotflex der Netzhaut. Ich bin der Weiterbildung zur Augenärztin und finde es sogar ein bisschen schade, dass dieses Phänomen heute so oft unterdrückt wird, da ein fehlender oder alterierter Rotreflex besonders bei Kindern auf Augenerkrankungen, zum Beispiel Tumor oder grauer Starr, hinweisen kann, die ansonsten oft zu lange unerkannt bleiben können. Leuchtend rote Augen, besonders bei Kleinkindern, sind also was Gutes.
Das heißt, man konnte mit diesen Fotos früh rechtzeitig bei Kindern feststellen, dass ein Tumor herrscht.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das heisst, Leute sind zum Arzt gegangen, haben ihre verwackelten hässlichen Fotos mitgenommen aus dem Urlaub und haben gefragt, stimmt was mit meinen Augen nicht oder habe ich nur eine sehr gute Kamera, weil ein Auge ist normal. Auch die langweiligste Filmprämisse wäre so ein Gruppenfoto, alle haben rote Augen, nur Johnny nicht. Johnny hat keine roten Augen. Johnny, Johnny, kommst du mal bitte? Ja? Warum hast du denn keine roten Augen auf dem Foto? Hier, guck mal, da waren wir doch alle. Oh, tatsächlich, bin ich anders? Habe ich Superkräfte? Nee, du hast einen Tumor. Das ist ein Tumor, zwei Tumoren. Gut, eine relativ, vielleicht eine Serie, vielleicht eine einteilige Miniserie oder so. Oder ein Werbespot. Ein Werbespot, auch gut. Trailer. Ja, Werbespot für, weil anscheinend wird das heute unterdrückt durch, ich glaube, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, aber durch so eine Art Vorblitz, dass immer kurz bevor der tatsächliche Blitz kommt, kommt noch so ein Blitz kurz davor. Achtung, hey, hier, der schon mal sagt, Achtung, gleich Blitz und dann hat das Auge, das ist ja super schnelles Auge, das ist ja das schnellste Organ und dann hat das noch eine Sekunde, sich einzustellen. Ich nehm die Kamera, blendet dann das Rot aus. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich auch nicht. Darum geht es auch nicht. Wir wollen es aber auch nicht wissen. Nee, darum geht es nicht. Deswegen diese angehende Augenärztin deutet darauf hin, dass der technische Fortschritt uns auch im Weg stehen kann in der Früherkennung von dem grauen Star. Star. Star. Star. Nee, Star. Kein, nur ein R. Star. Und ja, also vielleicht seitdem schießen die Augentumore und Augenerkrankungen hoch, weil man sie nicht mehr rechtzeitig erkennen kann. Ja, aber nochmal meine Frage. Das heißt, es gab wirklich einen Ansturm auf die Arztpraxen. Mit dem ganzen dem ganzen Fotoalbum von FKK-Bildern gesagt hat, meine Frau hat hier auf allen Fotos keine roten Augen. Was ist da los? Man würde doch niemals zum Arzt gehen, wenn man sagt, das ist deltsam. Man würde doch sagen, wow, endlich ein gutes Bild. Du gehst ja nicht mit einem richtigen Bild zum Arzt und sagst, was ist denn hier falsch.
Aber es muss doch so Gruppenfotos geben, wo wirklich so ein Abifoto, wie wo einfach wie so eine Fledermaus-Höhle, wo 50 rote Augenpaare, nur eine Person, nur eine Person. Lea, Lea hat keine roten Augen. Lea lebt heute aber auch nicht mehr, weil sie gestorben ist. Hat dann irgendwann Mrs. Metastasen gebildet. Ja, das tut uns sehr, sehr leid, aber immer noch ein Megafoto. Aber gutes Foto. Und dann der aus dem Foto-AK dann einfach nochmal gesagt hat, ja, geh dann nochmal rüber und dann einfach schön die Augenfarbe reingemalt mit so einem Pinsel. Welche Augenfarbe hast du? Rot, grün? Werbung. Mit der Unterstützung von unseren fantastischen Kollegen von Cyberport. Wir können es einfach nicht lassen, Cyberport, da fühlen wir uns wohl.
Einfach die richtige Technik.
Können wir euch heute ein neues, fantastisches Produkt vorstellen aus dem Hause Hewlett Packard? Ja, und zwar geht es heute um den HP NVX 360 Evo und das ist ein Notebook. Denn das ist ein sogenannter Convertible Laptop und dank 360-Grad-Schnier könnt ihr den Display einmal komplett um 360 Grad drehen, so dass ihr es quasi auch als Tablet nutzen könnt. Alleine das macht schon eine Menge Spaß, da einfach das auf und wieder zuzuklappen, aber ihr könnt ihn natürlich auch noch als fantastischen Notebook benutzen mit Intel-Evo-Plattformen und leistungsstarkem Intel Core i7-Prozessor. Ihr könnt den Display auch als Touch-Display benutzen und mit dem Windows-Ink sogar einfach drauf rummalen, wie ihr das wollt, direkt auf dem Display. Also cool in der Uni, dann mal wirklich schriftlich die ganzen Sachen festzuhalten, die ihr da so gesagt bekommt. Und sicher ist das Ding auch noch, dank IR-Kamera, Fingerprint-Sensor oder Pincode. Ich weiß nicht, bei Cyberport ein fantastisches Angebot, jagt das nächste, Wenn da nichts für euch dabei ist, dann habt ihr vielleicht einfach keine Ahnung von Technik. Ganz im Gegensatz. Habt ihr einen kompletten Schaden, dann lasst euch mal untersuchen. Ansonsten vielen, vielen Dank an Cyberport und ihre fantastischen Produkte. Cyberport, einfach das Beste, das Beste, was wir technikmässig in Deutschland zu bieten haben. Gute Technik, Cyberport. Werbung. Ich habe nämlich mein Abi-Jahrbuch gefunden, wo, was auf vielen Ebenen lustig ist, die Umfragen sind lustig, die verschiedenen Texte, die Texte über die LK sind lustig und so, wo ich dann aber sehr laut lachen musste, ist die Fotos dann immer. Jeder LK hat sich dann für einen Fototermin verabredet, hat dann irgendwie den Lehrer nachgemacht, der kam in meinem Anzug, dann haben wir uns alle den Anzug angezogen und waren dann an so ein Gruppenfoto gemacht. Und ich habe offensichtlich jeden dieser Termine vergessen. Aber es gibt immer so zwei, drei aus der Gruppe, die diesen Termin vergessen haben. Also es gab immer einen Lehrer, der hat immer Krawatte getragen. Und alle Schüler haben sich Krawatte angetragen. Nur irgendjemand hat die Mail nicht bekommen. Ja, weil ich hatte einen Hoodie an, weil ich habe den Mail nicht bekommen. So, und nicht nur in meinem Deutschen LK, sondern auch in meinem Mathe-LK hatte ich das auch verkackt, hatte auch ein falsches T-Shirt an. Und es gibt immer, aber auf jedem dieser Bilder gibt es immer zwei, drei, die es versteckt haben. Du, das kann aber auch ein Frühwarnzeichen für Krebs sein, ist ja schon klar. Du musst mit diesem Bild zum Arzt gehen und sagen, Entschuldigung, was ist denn da los? Ich habe als einziger keine Krawatte an. Legen Sie sich sofort hin. Oh Gott sei Dank, mittlerweile ist man ja so gut erreichbar, auf so vielen Social Media Plattformen, dass alle diese Mail bekommen. Diese Fotos waren aber hilfreich für uns herauszufinden. Aber gab es schon mal bei so, liebe Ärzte da draußen, hattet ihr schon mal ein Hole in one? Also dass so ein Patient kommt zu euch und sagt, ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe genau hier einen Tumor und der Arzt sagt, ja exakt so war es. Es gab keine Anzeichen dafür, aber einfach so ganz früh erkennungsmäßig, rein aus einem Gefühl heraus, was unmöglich eigentlich noch überhaupt keine Anzeichen gibt, noch keine Symptome, aber man sagt einfach so, ich gehe jetzt einfach mal blind links in irgendeiner Praxis, ich gehe jetzt einfach mal zum Fussarzt und sage, ich glaube, mein linker Fuss, da ist was und tatsächlich haben wir ihn gefunden. Da ist so ein kleiner Maulwurf drin, dann hat er gesagt, wenn der gewachsen wäre, der Maulwurf, dann hätten sie ein richtiges Fussproblem gehabt, aber jetzt ziehen wir dann raus den kleinen Schlingel und weg damit. Ja, ich nehme auch so, wie häufig stimmen denn so Selbstdiagnosen, die man sich herausgefunden hat, rausgesucht hat im Netz.
Aber mir stimmen die dann häufig dann mal.
Und einmal habe ich auch versucht, da hatte ich so eine weirden, in der Handinnenfläche, so eine weirde Punkte,
so ganz wenige, aber an einer Stelle, habe mich genervt, bin ich zum Arzt gegangen und wusste genau, was es ist.
Wie Punkte? So kleine braune Punkte und dann auch so leichte Erhebungen, da wo Hornhaut war, merkwürdigerweise.
Und dann bin ich dann zum Arzt gegangen und ich wusste, ich habe es genau gefunden, was es ist.
So ein spezieller Ausschlag, keine Ahnung, da gibt es eine Salbe, dann war der weg.
Und habe genau im Internet gefunden, ich habe auch lange gesucht, weil es so sehr speziell und sehr einfach zu beschreiben war,
weil es so kleine, kreisförmige, braune, mini braune Punkte war, anstellen, wo Hornhaut ist und so, es war sehr einfach zu googeln, also es war sehr schwierig zu googeln, aber dann einfach zu googeln im Sinne von, man hat nur ein Ergebnis bekommen, was sinnvoll war und alle anderen Symptome haben mir nicht gepasst und dann habe ich diese Hand gezeigt und er hat gesagt, ja, ich glaube, es ist das und das. Und ich wusste, nee, es ist nicht, weil das habe ich auch gefunden, dass das kommt, wenn ich google. Aber das kann es aus diesen und diesen Gründen nicht sein. Und dann habe ich den da so hinlenken wollen, weil ich wollte dem nicht, weil ich denke mir, wenn ich jetzt sage, ja, das ist der und der Ausschlag mit dem und dem Namen, den habe ich gefunden, dann denkt er, ach Gott, so ein Spacko, nein, ist nicht. Nee, dann aus Trotz diagnostiziert er was anderes.
Würde ich auch so machen.
Wenn da so ein Patient kommt mit so einem Internetwissen und sagt, ja, ich glaube, ich habe hier im Pneunoporax, habe ich hier den und den asymptomatisch, blablabla, würde er sagen, okay, weißt du was, du trägst jetzt einen fucking Gips, du gibst jetzt beide Beine ein.
Gips und eine Zahnspange, christene Zahnspange, Zahnspange mit dem Bügel.
Ja, mir ist scheißegal, ob deine Krankheit geheilt wird, aber dir müssen wir jetzt eine Lektion erteilen. Ja, und ich verstehe es. Ich würde die Zahnspange tragen. Ja, hundertprozentig. Aber das war es nämlich nicht. Und dann habe ich den dahingelenkt, weil ich habe den subtil dahingelenkt und dann hatte ich auch recht. Er hat mir eine Salbe verschrieben, exakt dafür, die ich auch recherchiert hatte, habe ich bekommen und war weg nach drei Tagen. Und der Arzt senkt sein Haupt, seufzt, zieht seinen Kittel aus und gibt dir seinen Kittel und sagt, gut, du bist jetzt der neue Arzt, du bist besser als ich. Sie, Herr Doktor Google. Herr Doktor Net Doktor. Tietze. Net Punkt Doktor Punkt Tietze. Ja, das ist wie in so einer Stammesgesellschaften. Wenn jemand den König besiegt, ist er der neue König. Und so ist es beim Arzt auch. Auch wenn jemand klüger ist als der Arzt, dann übernimmt er die Praxis, dann gehört ihm alles und kann entscheiden, welche Süßigkeiten auf der Rezeptionsscheide stehen.
Und ich würde da einfach mal schön die langen Twigs, die richtig langen Prügel, die extra langen Twigs-Prügel da reinballern.
So richtig so eine Torte, einfach eine fucking Torte dahin stellen. Eine Torte.
Eine Torte und Schokoladenbrunnen mit so einer ganzen Variation von Früchten einfach so fucking all in gehen auf der Rezeptionssüssigkeiten-Seite. Was so, ich war jetzt neulich wieder beim Arzt und ich weiß nicht, wie du beim Arzt bist, aber ich bin quasi nie beim Arzt. Nie. Eigentlich nur einmal im Jahr zum Zahnarzttermin. Weil da muss man dann ja immer noch dieses lustige Bonusheft abgeben, wo man Stempel bekommt, freue ich mich immer, muss ich immer lachen, kriege ich wieder ein Stempelchen mit meinem Heft und das ist immer dieser jetzt gerade am Ende des Jahres, muss ich immer lachen, über einen Stempel, kriege ich ein Stempel, Stempelchen. Und dann freue ich mich immer drüber und deswegen einmal im Jahr bin ich beim Arzt und jetzt war ich wieder noch nicht beim Zahnarzt und ich finde das ja einfach fantastisch, weil dann liegst du da auf diesem perfekt für dich gemachten Liegestuhl, dann kommt diese, alles ist ja perfekt für diesen Moment abgestimmt, alles läuft zusammen, alle Zahnräder greifen ineinander, dann hast du oben diese Lampe, die ja auf dich scheint, aber nicht blendet, das macht die ja auch ganz toll, und man fühlt sich wahnsinnig toll, einmal hat nämlich der Arzt dann in meinem Mund so rumgeprockelt und dann hat er das Gerät dann auf mir abgelegt, so auf meinem Bauch. Dann habe ich mich so wahnsinnig irgendwie gebraucht gefühlt, wie jemand, der auch gerade irgendwie helfen konnte bei Diagnose. Stell dir vor, du würdest seine Hand aufmachen und der legt es da rein, du würdest es selber halten. Und dann immer so, ja, das brauche ich es wieder, dann gebe ich es ihm wieder. Oh, das wird mich so stolz machen. Aber ich fand, das hat mich so weirdly stolz gemacht. Und es ist ja auch der Grund, dass man immer diese Schläuche im Mund hat und so nicht lachen darf, dass ich dann auch manchmal einfach lachen muss beim Arzt, weil wenn er dann solche Sachen macht, wie Dinge auf mich ablegen, weil ich dachte mir so, das ist irgendwie süss, so ein Bohrer liegt jetzt auf mir, weil ich bin auch gleichzeitig Tisch und Patient.
Ja, ich hatte ja lange Zartspange und da gibt es oft so Momente, wo irgendwas so fest trocknet in deinem Mund, irgendwie so diese Passformen und die dann rauszukriegen ist sehr schwer und da müssen beide Kieferorthopädenassistenten dann ziehen und die sagen dann, du musst jetzt mithelfen mit deiner Zunge, du musst mit der Zunge von der anderen Seite drücken und das ist so ein richtiges Gemeinschaftsding, so eins, zwei, drei, du mit deiner Zunge drückst so fest mit deiner Zunge, wie du noch nie gedrückt hast und denkst, ja, die Zunge ist der stärkste Muskel im Körper, aber ich weiß nicht, ob meine Zunge wirklich stark genug ist für diese Aufgabe und du gibst einfach alles mit der Zunge. Man ist nicht gut darin, Dinge mit seinem Mund auch zu erfüllen oder so. Die Zunge ist ein weirdes Organ. Man weiß nicht genau, was sie macht, wo sie gerade ist, wie sie gerade aussieht. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wenn meine Zunge jetzt gerade, wenn ich L mache oder so, wie geformt ist. Da gibt es ja die eine Folge der Simpsons, ja, ja, ja, ja, mit Jebediah Springfield, wo diese Zunge dann rausfällt, die auch so eine ganz komische Form noch nach hinten hatte. Aber auch da, manchmal ist es ganz so, so manche Körperteile trainiert man ja aktiv und manche nicht so. Und die Zunge, wahrscheinlich haben manche Leute eine stärkere Zunge als die anderen. Haben wir eine getrainierte Zunge, weil wir oft öffentlich reden? Weil wir oft öffentlich reden. Aber kennst du es nicht, du machst einen Zungenkuss und denkst dir, die Zunge packe ich locker. Also du hast ja gar keine Chance gegen mich. Also wirklich dann so dagegen drücken, unser Schwertkampf. Habe ich nichts. Nee, ich kriege immer gespiegelt, ich habe eine sehr weiche Zunge und ich verliere regelmäßig Zungenküsse. Ja, das ist aber verstecktes Feedback, wenn jemand sagt, du hast so eine weiche Zunge, heißt es, du trainierst nicht genug Stefan. Du musst mal ein bisschen Krafttraining machen mit der Zunge. Ja, aber das ist was Gutes, wenn man eher eine weiche Zunge hat. Ich musste aktiv meine Lippen trainieren, nachdem ich meine Spange hatte, weil ich hatte den Reflex, dass ich zu faul war, meinen Mund zuzumachen. Und der Mund hat aber den Reflex, dass er nicht sabbert. Und das heißt, wenn du die Lippen nicht richtig zumagst, dann drückt sich die Zunge zwischen die Zähne, zwischen die Zahnreihen, damit es zu ist. Und dadurch, also das sieht man von außen nicht, das sieht man von außen nicht, also du machst halt natürlich schon den Mund zu. Du strickst quasi immer so ein bisschen die Zunge raus. Habe ich auf jeden Fall gemacht und das ist natürlich ein Problem, weil die Zunge über die Jahre hinweg, Jahrzehnte hinweg deine Zähne verformt, weil wie gesagt, Zunge ist sehr starker Muskel und drückt die Zähne weg und dann dann musste das abtrainiert werden und gesagt, ja, sie haben sehr, sehr schwache Lippen. Wo ich auch gesagt habe, ja, das wollen wir erst mal sehen, Frau Lein. Und dann musste ich aber aktiv meine Lippen trainieren mit so einer Art Entenschnabel aus Gummi, die man sich zu sagen hat. Ich habe uns aber auch einfach einen zu humiliaten, das ist unglaublich. Unglaublich. Was auch wirklich erbärmlich so, du sitzt dann irgendwie zu Hause rum und drückst dann so mit deinen zusammengespitzten Lippen auf so einem Gumminöppel rum. Und seitdem habe ich sehr, sehr starke Lippen. Ich würde manchmal gerne, nicht aus sexuellen Gründen, aber Teenagern beim Everyday Life zugucken. Weil wenn mir jemand so geguckt hätte, mit meinen weirden Spangen und Bügeln und Dingen, die man mir in den Mund steckt, damit sich Dinge nicht verformen, dann diese weirden, diese Saugglocke, die ich hatte für meine Trichterbrust, wo ich immer meine quasi meine Brust so rausgevakuumiert habe. So habe ich dann da gesessen und Tournear auf Mangel geguckt. Also das sind wirklich Anblicke, wo man sagt, das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Carina sitzt neben dir und du überlegst, soll ich meinen Arm um sie legen, aber was ist mit meinem Saugnapf?
Was ist mit meinem Saugnapf, meinem Zahnbügel und meinem Entenschnabel in meinem Mund?
Und den Tampons in meiner Nase, weil ich ja dann doch auch Nasenbluten habe, durch den Stress, ist ja auch klar.
Ist eine schwere Zeit, ist wirklich die schwerste Zeit.
Und dann habe ich jetzt beim Zahnarzt, was fantastisch ist, ich hatte ein kleines Erfolgserlebnis, weil das Schlimmste mit dem Zahnarzt ist immer, finde ich, der Kampf gegen das Schlucken müssen.
Weil ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass ich häufig schlucken muss, aber dann haben die dann so, wenn die dann so Dinge sauber machen oder sowas oder was wegschleifen und so, springen die da rum und dann haben die ja schon, weil man nicht das runterschlucken soll auch so viel, haben die ja dann immer, war da eine Zahnarztgehilfin und die hatte dann so ein Saugding in der Hand. Ja, der Sauger ist dein Freund, der Sauger nimmt den überflüssigen Speichel im Mund in sich auf. Ja, gern gesehener Gast. Gern gesehener Gast in meinem Mund, der nimmt den so mit und dann in so einem durchsichtigen Schlauch, damit der Arzt auch sieht, ob da viel Blut mitkommt, keine Ahnung. Ob da noch ein halber Leibniz-Kekst drin, ob da noch ein bisschen Twix rumlungert. Von den langen Twix, die da vorne an der Rezeption rumladen. Die ganzen Karamellstücke zwischen den Zellen. Von der Torte, die ganzen Marzipanstücke, der Bräutigam auf der Torte vorne, der weirte Bräutigam. Den man sieht durch diesen Schlauch. Nein! Ja, und das fand ich immer auch sehr lustig, dass man das dann sieht. Und dann hat die das aber nicht richtig gemacht. Die hat das nicht so schön in Richtung, ich sag mal, Speichelherd gebracht, so dass noch zu viel Speichel in den Mund, weil ich ab und zu schlucken musste viel. Dann kam es aber zu dem tollen Moment, irgendwie musste sie dann weg und durfte ich selber meinen eigenen Sauger halten. Herrlich. Weißt du, wie cool das ist? Ja. Du spürst genau im Mund, wo genau die Speichelherde sind, wo du hin musst mit dem Sauger und der Arzt hatte freies Spiel. Mein Mund weit offen, Augen weit auf, Mund weit auf, er konnte machen, was er wollte, konnte sich selbst verwirklichen in meinem Mund.
Und ich konnte schön spuckefrei, speichelfrei, hatte keine Angst, musste nicht mehr so viel schlucken und so, war nicht verkrampft da, hatte meinen eigenen Schlauch.
Ja.
Dann wurde ich übermütig, dann war er irgendwie kurz fertig und ich habe mich dann kurz aufgerichtet und dabei den Mund zugemacht.
Oh.
Hat aber den Sauger noch im Mund.
Was dazu führt, dass so ein weirdes Vakuum in deinem Mund entsteht. Wenn du den Staubsauger hast und vorne das Ding drauf fällst, plötzlich wurde mein Mund so komplett über die Wangen zusammengesogen. Und es kam zu so einem ganz weirden Geräusch, das gemerkt, wie aus deinericheröhre die Luft rausgesogen wurde. Musst du ganz schnell den Sauger rausnehmen, wurde ich ein bisschen übermütig. Das Schlucken ist echt ein Problem. Mir ist mir tatsächlich passiert, dass ich die komplette Hand von der Assistentin verschluckt habe. Bis zum Unterarm habe ich die komplett weg verschluckt. Da war die Assistentin in mir drin. Die war weg und da dachte ich mir, jetzt rein oder raus, ziehst durch, einfach komplett weggeschluckt. Weggeschluckt. Einfach passiert, dass die haben ihren Verschleiß an Assistentinnen, manchmal sind die weg, aber da hatte ich kurz richtig Angst, als diesen Sauger da im Mund hatte. Ich kann es dir vorstellen, weil im schlimmsten Fall wirst ja einmal komplett du selber durchgesaugt. Ich dachte auch, ich drehe mich auf links. Dein Innen wird nach aussen gesaugt und dann ist alles weg und du bist dann hohl. Einfach wie so ein Nikolaus. Was hat ja auch schon so eine Saugkraft. Enorm. Aber ich glaube, man kann ja, kann man als Privatperson sich so einen Sauger für zu Hause kaufen. Weil ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock mehr auf Stucken. Ich bin an einem Punkt, wo ich sage, nee, ich will da einfach produzieren. Aber bist du nicht wie ein Springbrunnen? Ist man nicht so eine Art Springbrunnen, wo das Wasser, was man schluckt, braucht der Körper ja wieder?
Nein, der braucht es nicht.
Der macht Verlust. Das ist nicht wie Trinken.
Körper macht Verlust.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen so ein Perpetuum mobile.
Das ist ein Negativgeschäft.
Man hält sich für den Körper ein Negativgeschäft.
Ich glaube, wir halten uns ein bisschen selbst am Leben damit.
Nein, tun wir nicht.
Das ist kein Problem.
Du glaubst, in dem Körper kannst du 30 Prozent sich Perpetuum mobile oder was?
Du glaubst doch nicht, im Ernst, dass der eine Unterschiede zwischen, ah, das ist Speichel, das kommt auf den Müll und, ah, das ist das Wolvikwasser. Nein, das ist gegen die Gesetze des Universums. Du kannst nicht genauso viel Energie aus Speicheln rausziehen, wie du reinziehst. Ich glaube, wir trockenen aus... Stopp, nein. Aber ohne Scheiß können wir jetzt einen Arzt anrufen. Was passiert, wenn wir immer spucken würden? Das habe ich mir auch bei Fussballern gedacht, wo das zu so einer Gewohnheit, so einem Automatismus wird. Wachen das nicht Boxer auch beim Training, dass dadurch der Körper noch mehr belastet wird, und du mehr abnimmst, wenn du die ganze Zeit ausspuckst und so? Ist das denn so, weil man... Der Körper muss das ja herstellen. Meinst du, der hat da irgendwie noch zwei Eimer Spucke im Keller stehen und holt sich das einfach raus. Der muss das ja herstellen, relativ ... Ich glaube, wir trocknen langsam aus. Wir trocknen langsam aus, wenn wir immer die Spucke wegsaugen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber du kannst nicht deine Spucke trinken und davon überleben. Das ist Quatsch, Stefan. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Das ist keine Wüstenstrategie, zu sagen, ich kann da durchlaufen durch die Sahara, ich trinke einfach meine eigene Spucke. Nee, aber rennt bitte nicht mit dem offenen Mund rum, dass euch die Spucke wegverdunstet, dass ihr im Mund. Und hört diesen Podcast nicht so oft, weil sonst bleibt euch die Spucke weg. Sonst bleibt euch einfach die Spucke weg. Das ist ein aufregender Podcast, bleibt euch die Spucke weg. Wie tief ist eigentlich die Wüste? So. Also Sahara, gut, ich stehe da jetzt, Sand, Sand, Sand, soweit das Auge sieht. Wie tief ist das? Ist das wirklich so eine Art Ozean tief, so Kilometertief Sand oder ist man nach zwei Metern da dann irgendwie auf der Hüpfburgoberfläche, wo auch immer das darauf basiert? Ich glaube, an den meisten Orten der Wüste kommt, wenn du zu einem relativ gräbst, ein Sarkophag.
Gut, okay.
Erstmal schon mal das.
Und dann gräbst du durch den Sarkophag, durch Sorry, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Sorry, Entschuldigung, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Sorry, Ach, Dann kommst du direkt in die Hölle, oder was?
Es ist ein Eingang durch.
Ah, okay.
Nein, ich glaube, danach kommt erst mal, ich glaube, der Sand wird unangenehmer. Damit meine ich. Dichter. Nee, der müsste doch feiner werden. Bei einer Chipstüte hast du unten die feinsten Krümel. Es ist das Gegenteil eines Chip-Systems. Warum? Weil oben Wind ist, oben ist Reibung, unten sind die Brocken, unten sind die Felsen, die es nicht angreift. Oben sind die Gezeiten, oben ist Regen, oben ist Sturm. Aber der feine Sand rieselt durch bis nach unten. Nee, der rieselt nicht durch. Inwiefern unterscheidet sich die Sahara jetzt von der Chips-Tüte in der Hinsicht? Das musst du jetzt mal wirklich erklären. Weil oben, das wäre wie eine Chipstüte. Ja, schüttet doch bei Chipstüte auf.
So, oben hast du Regen, oben hast du die Gezeiten, oben trampeln Trampeltiere im Wassen des Wortes drüber, oben werden Kriege gefochten, unten die Chips sind im Feuchten, höchstens. Aber da passiert ja nichts mit den Chips unten. Aber oben geht ja ganz viel los. Da sind ja wirklich dem Unwetter ausgesetzt und so weiter und Winden. Ich kann mich nur wiederholen an diesem Punkt. Aber wie tief muss man graben? Also ist es wirklich ein Meter oder ist es 100 Meter? Oder ist es wirklich, weil ist es, ich stelle mir bei der Wüste immer eher so ein Ozean vor, das ist wirklich so richtig, richtig viel.
Wie ein Bällebad letztlich, stellst du dir vor.
Ja, im Grunde so. Gibt es denn ein Bällebad, das über Manns hoch ist oder ist das Erstickungsgefahr?
Bällebad?
Nee, das geht, oder?
Da habe ich keine Erstickungsgefahr.
Kriegt man weniger Luft an den Bällen?
Wenn die sehr schwer sind vielleicht, dann hat man vielleicht die Lunge eingedrückt. Die schwersten Bälle sind ganz unten. Wo wären die kleinsten Bälle beim Bällebad? Oben oder unten? Unten doch. Ja, in einem geschützten Raum. Du hast einen Haufen Vierjähriger, die da halt rumrumoren und halt irgendwie noch irgendwie Maronese am Mund haben und irgendwie noch ein paar Chicken Nuggets in der Hosentasche haben. So, die lässt du los auf so ein Bällebad. Da sind unterschiedlich große Bälle drin. Ja, da glaube ich ist da... Nach einer Stunde, nach 20 Minuten. Wie ist die Situation dann? Die wühlen da durch. Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, die kleineren Bälle sind unten da. Die rieseln durch. Und jetzt ist der Unterschied zwischen dem Bällebad und der Sahara. Jetzt hast du ein Problem. Die Gezeiten. Du kannst nicht auf jede Frage die Gezeiten antworten. Aber ich bin kein Tobi, ich frage jetzt nicht genau nach, was sind Gezeiten, sondern ich sage, okay, Gezeiten, alles klar. Und schreib dich einfach auf meine lange Liste von Leuten, mit denen ich keine tiefgründigen Gespräche mehr führen kann. Nein sie keine Ahnung wie tiefgründig sind. Nein, nicht auf die Liste. Wie tiefgründig meine ich jetzt Themen, die sich spezifisch darum drehen, was unter der Erde sind. Wie tief? Wie tief? Drei Meter? Nein, aber hä? Ich will nicht auf die Liste gesetzt werden. Ja, doch, tut mir leid. Hast du die themenspezifisch oder bin ich jetzt auf der Blacklist für alle Themen? Nee, nee, ist die themenspezifisch. Nur für tiefgründige Themen zum Thema Grund und Boden. Ich bin gerade bei Geologie-Themen abgerutscht auf die Liste. Nee, nur alles, was mit Boden zu tun hat. Also nicht mal, wir können uns weiterhin über Vulkan unterhalten. Ja, ja, Ukan, Windhose, das ist alles noch offen. Da macht ihr keine Sorgen. Vulkan kann ich mit dir reden. Ja, ja, klar. Ja, ja, nee, alles klar. Auf jeden Fall. Gut, dann ist ist mir recht egal. Schubladendenken ist ja auch okay, finde ich, wenn man in mehr Schubladen denkt. Ja, ab einer gewissen Anzahl ist es okay. Wenn du für jeden Mensch auf der Welt eine Schublade hast, dann ist es perfekt. Das ist aber nur die Hälfte. Du hast halb so viele Schubladen. Ja, wie viele Schubladen sind okay? Ja, drei Leute gehen in den Schubladen. Ich glaube, wenn man wirklich die gesamte Weltbevölkerung zusammenstellt, würde man finden, es gibt jemanden, der ist exakt so wie ich. Wo du denkst, wenn ich einen kenne, kann ich mir den anderen sparen. Nur halt Inder. Indischer Florentin. Ja, Indentin, der halt dann einfach sagt, okay, der ist gerne dasselbe, der hat auch seinen Podcast oder so. Einfach dasselbe. Ja, kann ich mir auch vorstellen, ehrlich gesagt. Die diskutieren gerade, was ist in der Poppadom-Tüte oben und was ist unten. Es ist einfach dasselbe, es ist einfach genau dasselbe nochmal. Guck mal, wollen wir einen Austausch machen mit denen? Ja, wir hatten ja schon unseren Franzosen-Austausch, was ziemlich Merde gelaufen ist, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Ja, richtig Merde. Ich wüsste sogar, was das bedeutet, wenn wir den gemacht hätten. Aber ohne Scheiß, wenn du was in die Hand nehmen musst, organisatorisch, ist es zum Schleppern verurteilt. Ja, absolut. Okay, gut. Du bist nämlich auf meiner Blacklist für Leute, die organisieren müssen. Danke, perfekt. Das war mein Ziel. Ich wollte da raus aus dieser Liste. Ich habe extra unseren Ausflug, unseren Campingausflug ein bisschen mittelmässig geplant. Das Petroleum, ich habe viel zu viel Petroleum. Den fand ich schön, weil wir zueinander gefunden haben, im ganzen Petroleumzelt. Ich habe 16 Liter Petroleum mitgenommen für unseren kleinen Ofen. Und am letzten Abend haben wir dann alles in die Luft gejagt, was auch Spaß gemacht hat. War schön, wir haben zueinander gefunden. Ja, wir haben zueinander gefunden. Das finde ich auch ganz gut. Harte Extremsituationen schweissen auch Menschen zusammen. Beziehungen halten länger, wenn sie in Extremsituationen begonnen werden, gefunden werden. Also wenn man zum Beispiel zu zweit innerhalb von einer Lawine verschüttet wurde, dann kann das eine sehr erfolgreiche Beziehung werden. Weil der Körper dann sagt so, ja, damit haben wir schon mal das Schlimmste überlebt, ich weiß, wie die Person in Extremsituationen ist. Einfach mal irgendwie so ein Geiseldrama, kann man buchen, man kann Geiseldrama buchen, mal irgendwie so erstes Tinder-Date, das dich und dein Date entführen. Finden Sie in einer Extremsituation zueinander. Tsunami zueinander. Ja, Tsunami sam, ja, okay. Ja, zusammen. Ich glaube, die Domain ist noch frei, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das ein gutes Zeichen ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Alarmglocke ist. Ich glaube, es ist eine Alarmglocke. Das ist doch eigentlich perfekt. Du bist in jemanden verliebt, wo du keine Chance hast. Die mag dich nicht, du stehst auf allen Listen, ganz oben drauf. Und dann hast du eigentlich nur noch die Möglichkeit, eine gemeinsame Geiselnahme zu haben. Und dann engagierst du so Hobby-Terroristen, die euch, genau euch beide entführt. Ja, finde ich super. Und dann zusammen, irgendwie macht man dann zusammen ein lustiges Video, man überlebt sich was, wer hält das Schild, wer macht irgendwie, wer versucht Morse-Code mit Augenzwinkern zu machen. Irgendwie so ein paar Gags muss man dann so ein bisschen gruppenarbeitmäßig machen. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Chance, dann zusammen durchzukommen, wenn dann man irgendwie auf der deutschen Botschaft dann ist, irgendwie zusammen, man teilt sich ein Zimmer und so. Das ist nett, glaube ich, Körper kann echt was entstehen. Wusstest du, dass die Band Revolverheld damals Tsunami-Killer hieß? Oh, wirklich? Und dann, aber seit dem Tsunami Ende 2004, nennt sich der Revolverheld dann oben in Revolverheld. Aber Revolverheld ist ein fantastischer Name dafür, dass es eine zweite Wahl war, muss man sagen. Ich nenne mir vor, die nenennen dich um den Revolverheld und dann geht so ein Revolverheld-Massaker los, Madison Square Garden, das Revolverheld-Massaker von 2007. Oh fuck, kann doch nicht sein. Wie nennen wir uns jetzt? Okay, wie wäre es mit Winnen denn sowas vielleicht? Oh nein, war Trade Center sowas in der Richtung, keine Ahnung, die unglücklichste Band der Welt einfach. Ja, Evolverheld. Auch Juli, die perfekte Bälle. Ja genau, Juli hat ja den Song genommen, der wurde dann auch nicht gespielt. Es gibt ja so Katastrophen-Playlists. Vor allem, ich bin ja gerade wieder im Herr der Ringe-Fieber, wisst ihr, Weihnachtszeit ist Herr der Ringe-Zeit bei mir. Und was ich auch ganz gerne mache, ist da in Promomaterial reinzugucken.
Weil man hat Herr der Ringe ja immer so als, ja, legendäre Trilogie vor Augen, aber dazu gab es natürlich, die waren auch in Late-Night-Shows, die Schauspieler, die waren irgendwie in so Presseinterviews, das wurde ja natürlich alles gemacht, die normale Promotion-Sache. Und es gibt eine ganz... Als wäre es ein normaler Film. Als wäre es ein ganz normaler Film. Und es gibt eine Reihe von Interviewen, hauptsächlich mit Viggo Mortensen, zum Thema, inwiefern kann man The Two Towers parallel ziehen zum 11. September. Weil das ist genau in der Zeit, bis ein paar Jahre später. Mittlerweile hat er gar nicht mehr im Verhältnis. Mittlerweile völlig egal. Aber damals kam halt der Film The Two Towers raus, relativ zeitnah zu dem Anschlag. Und natürlich war das dann Gesprächsthema, da hat natürlich jeder Gags gemacht, alle Late-Night-Shows. Und dann hast du da immer die Schauspieler stehen, die da zur Stellung beziehen müssen, die immer versuchen, auf möglichst diplomatische Weise zu sagen, das Buch wurde vor 50 Jahren geschrieben. Und das Buch heißt so, also heißt der Film so. Das war's. Ocean's Eleven musste umgeschnitten werden, das will ich nochmal hinten raus, ganz dollene. In der Flugzeugszene, oder was? Genau. Krass, die gibt es ja nicht mehr. In Oceans gibt es eine Szene nicht. Ursprünglich hieß es Oceans Nine-Eleven. Und man hat sich gesagt, der bleibt, dass es gar nicht machen. Erst ist Oceans Seven-Eleven. Das gab einen Riesenstreit. Dann ist Oceans 9-Eleven. Und er hat gesagt, okay, leider vergesst es. Warum hat Osama Benad nicht gesagt bei 7-Eleven? Weil dann wäre, er hätte zwei Ziele mit einer Klappe geschlagen. Eigentlich genial, ja, stimmt schon. Er hätte eine Supermarktkette ruiniert und Amerika. Ja, da hätte man so viel besser machen sollen. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Das ist ein anderes Thema, da hätte man noch mal ins Feedback-Gespräch gehen können. Richtig. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt zu spät. Du willst nicht über Sachen reden, die du vor 19 Jahren gemacht hast. Das ist auch so ein One-Hit-Wonder. Osama bin Laden wahrscheinlich 2018 noch so, oh, damals 9-11 genial. Er so, ja, das ist aber auch schon 17 Jahre her. Meine letzten Aktionen waren auch ganz cool, glaube ich. Das hat mich bestimmt auch genervt irgendwie. Immer nur auf diese eine Sache angesprochen worden. Die Ärzte wollen ja auch nicht, wenn da sind Schweine. Ja, klar. Kannst du jetzt nicht noch irgendwie, oh, Dendemann, endlich nicht schwimmen, so, ja, Megason. Ist ein Megason, aber ist jetzt auch mal gut. Ich meine, wir müssen auch ständig über Folge 32 reden, immer so, oh, Folge 32.
Und wir sagen ja, aber es ist halt auch schon 200 Folgen her.
Wir haben da wenig zu tun. Wir haben andere gute Sachen gemacht.
Es ist so, als würden wir zwei Fremde, als würden wir zwei Inder hören, die da reden.
Wir haben mit den Menschen nicht mehr so viel zu tun, außer den Namen.
Ich habe noch alte Fotos von mir gesehen, wo ich dachte, wer ist der Mensch?
Wer ist der Mensch? Ich gucke auf einen Menschen und ich glaube, in mir ist dieser Mensch immer noch irgendwo drin. Ja, der guckt raus und sagt, das bin ich. Hi, ich bin du. Aber wer ist dieser Mensch, der da in die Kamera guckt? Also du bist in der Zwiebel oder wie? Du hast alle vorherigen Versionen von dir noch als Schichten unter dir. Du bist wie so eine russische Puppe, so eine Matruschka-Puppe.
Davon gehe ich aus. Davon gehe ich bei jedem Menschen aus. Und du wächst und dann kriegst du immer mehr Schichten außenrum.
Was ja auch dein Donutprinzip unterschmalt, weil die ist ja auch innen hohl.
Irgendwann ist diese Matruschka ja hohl oder aus Holz.
Aber alles ist innen hohl.
Oder nicht? Wenn du nur die Dimensionen klein genug machst, ist alles hohl.
Im Endeffekt ist alles hohl. Der Donut ist ein Torus. Torus ist der Körper für einen Donut. Und es wäre der coolere Name gewesen für einen Donut. Ja, der Duncan-Torus oder was? Das ist für die Mathematiker. Also so müsste eigentlich so ein Unicafé heißen, Duncan-Torus. Gehört euch irgendein Kaffee bei Harvard oder so? Ich nenne es Dunkin Torus. Eigentlich eine gute Idee. Oder es gibt bestimmt auch für die Pizza irgendwie so einen mathematischen Begriff. Eben so ein Kreis. Starbucks gibt es doch bestimmt auch irgendwas. Ja. Was ist Starbucks? Ist ja auch im Prinzip nur eine Kernfusionskraftwerk. Ach so, ach so, okay. Irgendwie gibt es da nicht so blauer Riese, roter Zwerg, grüner Affe. Die Astronomen haben auch einen kompletten Schaden, muss man eigentlich mal sagen. Aber niemand traut sich, denen zu widersprechen, weil alle zu wenig Ahnung haben. Unter anderem, apropos nicht widersprechen dürfen, es gibt leider, leider, und da muss ich wirklich sagen, Wissenschaft reicht auch langsam, es gibt leider neue Erkenntnisse zum Thema Diversaurier. Ganz kurz, brich mal kurz ab, die Aufnahme. Alles klar. So, weil wir wollten darüber nicht sprechen. Ich habe dir gesagt, dass wir darüber nicht sprechen werden. Stefan, du musst die Wahrheit auch machen. Nein, wir müssen darüber nicht sprechen. Nein, du musst es anerkennen, du musst es konfrontieren. Was du nicht verstehst, ist, was man nicht anspricht, da kommen wir auf ein weirder Bogen der Folge, und es ist cool geframeworked jetzt alles. Wenn man Dinge nicht anspricht, existieren sie nicht. Nein, aber das stimmt nicht so, Stefan. Wenn man Dinge nicht anspricht, dann macht man sie auch nicht kaputt. Als Fan von Dinosauriern bist du Fan der Wissenschaft. Nein, ich bin Fan von Dinosauriern. Du kannst die beiden Dinge nicht trennen. Ohne die Wissenschaft wüssten wir gar nichts über Dinosaurier. Dann hättest du keine Bettdecke, dann hättest du keinen Schlafanzug, dann hättest du kein einziges Poster in deinem Zimmer. Du hättest keinen Turnister. Du hättest keinen Turnister. Also musst du auch sagen, an wessen süsser, süsser Brust ich hänge seit Jahren, ich muss nehmen, was ich kriege. Was auch immer da rauskommt, muss ich in mich aufnehmen. Und so auch die Wahrheit. Die Leute verdienen, ich bin da bei dir, die Leute verdienen die Wahrheit, aber was ist, wenn sie die Wahrheit nicht ertragen? Bist du bereit, die Wahrheit zu konfrontieren? Okay. Okay, soll ich wieder weiter machen? Ja, gut. Denn die Wissenschaft hat herausgefunden, nachdem sie uns schon so viele Coolness-Elemente der Dinosaurier genommen haben, Dinosaurier hatten Federn, hatten Birkenstocks an, hatten lange Haare, graue Haarchen, graue lange Haare, Pseudofedern, hat die Wissenschaft rausgefunden, dass ein T-Rex nicht wie ein Löwe brüllt. Ich muss es empathisch sagen, weil hier gehen jetzt auch viele
das ist ein Fantoom,
machen auf einer anderen Franchise kaputt.
Dinosaurier
haben gequakt.
Der T-Rex hat nicht gebrüllt,
gar gebellt,
zumindest gebellt.
Er hat auch nicht gerufen, geschrien,
er hat gequakt. Ja, tatsächlich, Wissenschaftler finden raus, dass Dinosaurier in ihrer Stimmenanatomie am ähnlichsten einer Gans sind, die quakt und trötet. Und ja, damit muss Jurassic Park neu gedreht werden. Stefan ist in Tränen ausgebrochen. Es tut mir wirklich leid, Stefan. Süße, salzige Tränen laufen über seinen Dinosaurier-Pullover. Und es tut mir wirklich leid, aber ... Ein T-Rex! Lauft schnell! Lauft schnell weg. Nein, eben nicht. Ihr müsst nicht laufen, weil sie konnten noch nicht rennen. Sie waren zu schwer zum Rennen, die haben nicht mal gejagt, die haben Aas gegessen, weil die so langsam waren, die konnten niemand erreichen. Ja, wir haben uns, die Wissenschaftler haben sich die Beinanatomie von T-Rex angeguckt und höchstwahrscheinlich sind sie so im Hoppserlauf haben sie sich bewegt. Wie man das kennt, wenn ein guter Song auf der Tanzfläche läuft und Ricarda läuft auf der Tanzfläche bei Single Ladies, dieses Rumpelstielchen-Tanz, die man jetzt kennt, wie man so langsam hervorisch auf die Tanzfläche macht. Im schnellen, fröhlichen Hoppserlauf sind sie dahin gewetzt. Relativ langsam, aber fröhlich. Also auch da, wie gesagt, viele Bilder von Dinosauriern müssen leider überarbeitet werden. Gott. Das einzige, glaube ich, was... Gequ ich, was jetzt noch der Sagnagel wäre, glaube ich, für Dinosaurier wäre, wenn man sagt, wir haben da leider wissenschaftlich in der Nomenklatur viele Fehler gemacht, wir müssen die Namen leider ändern und der Tyrannosaurus Rex muss jetzt umbenannt werden in den Schnapper. Alfred J. Rex.
In den Rotaugen-Schnapper müssen wir jetzt leider umbenennen, einfach weil wir sonst die Biologie nicht mehr anwenden können. Das wäre, glaube ich, noch der letzte Sargnagel. Weil solange die coole Namen haben, glaube ich, kommt man durch. Weil es gibt wenig Fans von Tieren, die uncoole Namen haben. Wie viele Kuscheltiere von Ameisenbären findest du? Null. Aber jedes Kuscheltier, das du findest, das ein Kind gerne in den Armen wiegt, hat einen coolen Namen, Affe, Bär. Da ist ja auch alles falsch, glaube ich, mit dem Ameisenbär, der ist so cool eigentlich. Lange, lange, distinktiv Nase, dieses Fell, dieses Triko-artige Fell. Ich meine, es gibt den Nasenbär. Es gibt übrigens ein Bild, den wir haben von einem Schmetterling, der einfach die Zahl 23 so als Form auf sich drauf hat, was ich mega finde. Aber steht es auf den Flügeln oder ist es die Form der Flügel? Nein, auf dem Flügel ist es ein schwarzer Flügel und in Weiss steht es in so einer perfekt Comic-Suns-artigen Schrift, wie so ein Relica, die 23. 20. Und warum nicht? Weil die sind ja random, diese Flecken, diese weissen Flecken auf den schwarzen Flügeln. Warum kann es nicht mal einfach die perfekte Zahl 23 sein?
Warum kann es nicht mal ein Hakenkreuz sein? Es tut mir leid, aber es gibt manche Schmetterlinge, die so durch das Leben gehen. Ich meine, es gibt den Nasenbären. Der Nasenbär hat eine kürzere Nase als der Ameisenbär.
Ja, dessen Idee war das.
Warum gibt man denn nicht den Namen Nasenbären dem Bären, der die längste Nase hat?
Ja, das ist einfach zu faul.
Nein, weil man die nicht ändert wieder.
Aber das ist ja super änderbar.
Ich finde es total...
Aber ist 23 nicht eh diese Verschwörungstheorie-Nummer, wo es eh schon...
Gibt es ja nicht den ganzen Film mit Keanu Reeves?
Ich habe es nicht, dass ich ihn finde, aber ich habe ihn später gefunden. Und es sind Zahlen 89. Die 89. Aber es sieht nicht so aus wie ein Fake, weil das kann schon Sinn ergeben. Nee, genau. Und es ist auch nicht ganz... Also ich habe alles falsch erzählt tatsächlich. Also die Zahlen sind weiss, aber es ist mehr so ein weiss-schwarz gestreifter Flügel. So geringe, ja. Und in perfekter Comic-Sunschrift ist es 89. Aber hat da nicht irgendeinen Typograph das als Grundlage genommen für eine neue Schrift? Eine neue Schriftart. Weil das ist eine Schrift, die aus der Natur kommt. Aus der Natur. Das wäre ja total geil eigentlich. Ich schick's dir mal, du kannst es ja in die Shownotes packen. Ja. So, was machen wir jetzt? Wir sind ja jetzt auch unter die Profis gegangen. Andere Podcasts ziehen so ein bisschen an uns vorbei, so rein technisch, finde ich. Ja, auch was Webseiten angeht, hängen wir echt hinterher, aber ich finde, gute Podcasts brauchen auch keinen Schmuck, müssen durch ihren Content. Ja, schade, dass wir das auch nicht sind, von daher. Das stimmt natürlich. Aber sonst bin ich da auch deiner Meinung.
Naja, ich glaube, für die paar Simpsons-Fans, die es noch gibt, ist der Podcast nützlich, glaube ich.
Ein Shoutout an den Podcast Im Dunkeln über den Fall Rebecca, ein True Crime Podcast von zwei Investigativjournalistinnen, die da gerade einen richtig, richtig klasse Podcast machen.
Was ist los mit Rebecca?
Rebecca ist verschwunden, schon länger verschwundenunden seit 2019, war ja auch ein Riesending, zog ja auch viel Kritik auf sich, war der Fall, weil dann irgendwann der Schwager verdächtigt wurde, die ermordet zu haben und wurde dann veröffentlicht, also sein Bild und so, obwohl er jetzt glaube ich auch wieder freigelassen wurde mittlerweile. Also da gab es so ein paar weirde Dinge, Justiz-wise und da gibt es einen ganz fantastischen Podcast, den ihr gerne mal hören sollt. Und natürlich nochmal die Empfehlung Drinnis von unserer Kollegin Julia Becker und Chris Sommer, toller Podcast. Toller Podcast. Drinnis hört auf jeden Fall rein, super toll. Es war ein gutes Jahr für Podcast, glaube ich. Ja, also ich glaube, Corona hat gehol und ist allen in die Karten gespielt, muss man sagen. Weirderweise gibt es auch Branchen, die davon, muss man sagen, auch ein bisschen profitiert haben. Viele Leute hören Podcasts jetzt mehr. Aber wir hoffen alle, dass es irgendwie doch wieder normal wird. Wir machen nächste Woche noch eine Folge. Nächste Woche die große Weihnachtsfolge natürlich. Die große Weihnachts-Jahresrückblick-Folge. Der große Weihnachts-Countdown wird stattfinden. Und das wird nochmal großartig. Wir werden unsere Pullover anziehen. Ich habe leider den Fehler gemacht, dass ich, ich habe mir dieses Jahr ein Weihnachtspullover bestellt, aber leider so zeitig, dass der wahrscheinlich erst Anfang nächsten Jahres ankommt. Dann hat man ein Problem, weil ich werde den nicht ein Jahr lang in der Schublade lassen, sondern ich werde den auch schön anziehen. Wenn du so ein minimalistisches Einrichtungskonzept hast, Open Floor, Open Shelf System hast. Ja, ich habe Open Pile, also ich habe wirklich meine Kleidung in Haufen organisiert. Nur weil du das Englische sagt, ist es nicht besser. Doch, ich finde, das klingt besser. Es klingt wirklich besser, aber es ist nicht besser. Pile klingt besser als Haufen. Im Open Pile Living System. Also ich hoffe, dass ich nächste Woche hier im Weihnachtspullover sitzen kann. Du hast ja auch ein Saures Weihnachtspullover. Vielleicht können wir eine schöne, gemütliche Weihnachtsfolge machen mit ein bisschen Dekoration und einem lauwarmen Blühwein. Spekulatius Wasser. Und das wird grossartig. Spekulatius und Dr. Pepper. Und dann will ich von dir beiden wissen, was jeweils drin ist. Okay. Ansonsten habt eine schöne Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche, macht's gut. Und wir sagen Ciao. Das ist unser Catchphrase. Und wir sagen Ciao. Schau mal vor, an irgendeinem Punkt finden wir einfach einen neuen Catchphrase. Und alle so, hä? Und wir machen den genauso authentisch, dass man denkt, ja, dass man denkt, wir hätten den immer so gemacht, dass sie kurz denken, die sind irgendwie dann im neuen Universum. Das war's von uns. Wir sagen Ciao.au. Wir sagen tschau. It's the worst bird production.